[Music]
welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
gonna be my brain who dr. strange - and
spider-man 3 video Marvel made a couple
big announcements recently you probably
just saw the news so we'll break it all
down there's even some funny avengers
endgame Ghost Rider Easter eggs we'll
talk about if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we're doing an Amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
Doctor Strange moment on the video so
just going down the list trying to keep
this organized starting with number 5
recently you probably saw the headlines
that Sony moved Tom Holland and Marvel's
spider-man 3 from July next year to
November the reason they did that was
because they were gonna miss their
original productions start date by a
little while in rather than release
spider-man 3 in August they wanted to
release the movie during a major holiday
period so it could potentially earn more
money
spider-man far from home earned over a
billion dollars so you better believe
that Sony wants spider-man 3 to earn
even more money also they had just
delayed venom - let there be carnage and
that was gonna come out at the end of
June next year so there would have been
less than a month between venom 2 in
spider-man 3 and even though we're all
expecting some minor crossover in cameos
from spider-man in venom 2 they would
have wound up cannibalizing a lot of the
potential box-office profits for venom 2
so they just wanted some more space
between their big spider-man movies so
when Sony moved spider-man 3 to November
it caused another ripple effect and
Marvel delayed a couple more movies even
further it's not all bad news though it
actually is good news for a couple
movies so for Doctor Strange 2 was
originally supposed to come out next May
directed by a mr. spider-man himself Sam
Raimi everything seemed like it was
gonna be awesome we're all super pumped
to see what he does with the movie then
a couple weeks ago Marvel shifted all of
its Marvel phase 4 movie dates because
of the virus and it moved Doctor Strange
to to November next year the date that
spider-man 3 just took
so then Marvel had to delay Doctor
Strange 2 again until March 2022 so even
though that seems like a huge bummer
delaying movies does kind of suck it's
good news for both Doctor Strange - and
spider-man 3 for a couple reasons
in the case of spider-man three remember
the report awhile ago that there was
supposed to be a fan favorite Marvel
character who was also a lawyer as part
of the Mysterio fake video storyline
spider-man having to prove to the world
that he was innocent he didn't really
kill Mysterio Mysterio added his secret
identity in he had to deal with that
somehow to Kevin Smith had reported that
he'd heard from an insider that Marvel
intended for that character to be
daredevil but back when they were still
releasing the movie next July their
production schedule on spider-man 3 made
it almost impossible for them to use the
daredevil character because Marvel and
Netflix is contract for the defenders
characters states that Marvel can't use
them again in anything until two years
after their contract ended in that
two-year period isn't over until the end
of this year and originally Marvel would
have already been done filming
spider-man 3 by that time so three now
the sony has delayed the movie they
won't be filming it till a little bit
later in the year because of the virus
and even though that's kind of a bummer
they'll be free and clear to legally use
as much daredevil as they want and a lot
of you have asked about she-hulk because
she's another MCU lawyer that's getting
ready to debut on the Disney Plus series
in the next couple of years maybe the
lawyer in spider-man 3 that spoken up is
supposed to be her yes it is possible
but she Hulk and spider-man really
haven't had any meaningful history
together in the comics in spider-man and
daredevil have crossed over a bunch of
times
spider-man has even warned the daredevil
costume pretending to be daredevil and
daredevil has warned the spider-man
costume pretending to be spider-man they
also share a lot in common as characters
they're both written to be very grounded
heroes trying to protect their cities as
opposed to the more cosmic characters
dealing with universe shattering
galactic problems every day like Thor
and we're talking about spider-man being
framed here by a Mysterio and having to
clear his name there was actually an
episode of the spider-man animated
series from the 90s literally called
framed which was a big daredevil
crossover daredevil huh I like your
style
[Music]
Murdoch thinks you've been framed be
safe here until he can prove it you know
I'd love to see Peter Parker in the in
the in and and daredevil hangout there's
a wonderful episode issue of the comics
where um Matt Murdock has to defend
daredevil and because of the public
don't know and so he has Peter Parker
put on his daredevil outfit so that he
can sit in the docs you know great
storyline you also have the added
benefit of daredevil character kingpin
being a huge spider-man character at the
same time we all want to see kingpin in
the MCU at some point during a
spider-man's story finally off to Rikers
huh you know I think you've got more
enemies in there than I do if you think
this will be more than a minor
inconvenience gotta go so I think it
just makes way more sense to put
daredevil into a spider-man movie than
say someone like she-hulk but we'll find
out more about that soon number two what
about Ghost Rider there were reports
earlier this year that Marvel was after
Keanu Reeves for a role Kevin Feige had
even revealed that they had meetings
with Keanu every single phase going back
to Marvel phase 1 so about every two or
three years they'll have a meeting with
him about playing an MCU character Kevin
Feige didn't say which characters during
phase one phase two or phase three Keanu
would have played had he said yes but
recently we learned they had just met
with him about their upcoming Marvel
phase four movies and the latest rumor
was that it was actually for the new
version of Ghost Rider in the MCU
although I haven't heard any rumors
about plans for a new Ghost Rider solo
movie inside the MCU
there have been reports that Doctor
Strange 2 is supposed to have some new
Ghost Rider Easter eggs because the
story is taking Doctor Strange to a much
darker place introducing more concepts
like vampires goes supernatural MCU
characters teasing the upcoming Blade
movie Kevin Feige said his big thing and
waiting this long to do a blade reboot
in the MC was all about Doctor Strange
the supernatural character he felt like
now was the good time to do more
supernatural characters because they did
that first Doctor Strange movie and it
opened the doors wide on that part of
the MCU we have for years wanted to find
a new way into blade we love that
character we love that world now with
Doctor Strange and the supernatural
elements coming into the MCU it felt
like we could we could definitely start
exploring that Mahalo
once come in and meet with us and when
Mohali wants to meet you take the
meeting and I think he had just come off
of his second Academy Award and we were
talking very polite and he was talking
about what Fanny is and then he just cut
right to it and was like blade and we're
like yes so if they wind up using a new
ghostwriter in the MCU movies it sounds
like it's going to be in the darker
stuff the supernatural movies and Disney
Plus series like blade and Moon night
and hopefully Marvel is able to get
Keanu Reeves to say yes to a character
because I feel like he would work as a
number of different characters in the
MCU
so everyone poster fan cast for Keanu
Reeves in the new Marvel movies but
number one Ghost Rider Easter egg during
Avengers endgame this is actually kind
of funny some of you may have noticed
the connection so when they're all
arguing about how time travel works and
how Back to the Future lied to them
war machine suggests why don't they just
go back and kill baby Thanos to prevent
all this tragedy now you're gonna feel a
little discombobulated from the chrono
ship don't worry about it they say let
me ask you something if we can do this
you know go back in time why don't we
just find baby Thanos you know and first
of all that's horrible Spanos and
secondly time doesn't work that way
changing the past does it change then
the whole goes on to explain that
changing fantasies past won't erase the
future of versions of fan o's the one
who snapped everyone at the end of
Avengers infinity war it won't erase the
one from 2014 who they fight at the end
of Avengers endgame either as the
ancient one later explains to the Hulk
it will only create another branch time
reality where Thanos doesn't exist and
that is the exact plot of a Ghost Rider
story that was being published around
the same time as Avengers endgame was
coming out with cosmic Ghost Rider he
was a version of The Punisher who became
Ghost Rider in the future tries to
travel into the past to kill baby Thanos
to prevent all the terrible things that
he did but what happens is that he winds
up showing him mercy because he's just a
baby he hasn't committed any of these
acts yet he's still relatively innocent
and he tries to raise him to be good but
fails so miserably at being a father
that he winds up turning Thanos into a
different type of monster that's even
worse and Thanos takes the mantle of the
pun
sure when he grows up Punisher Santos
much worse than all the other versions
of fan OHS as you can imagine but if all
that Avengers end game time travel
branch realities stuff seems confusing
to you they're gonna explain that in
much greater detail during the Loki
series which was originally gonna
premiere next March but because of all
the virus delays they might not wind up
releasing that till next spring but it's
still coming out they're still making it
I'm sure it's gonna be great
I've already done videos about all those
Marvel phase for Disney Plus series
we'll get some more trailers for the
newer ones like Falcon and Winter
Soldier in one division pretty soon too
but everyone let me know in the comments
what do you want Marvel to do with their
new Ghost Rider and do you want them to
put daredevil in spider-man 3 now that
they can congratulations to the giveaway
winner from my last big spider-man video
Atari dad please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
details
everyone click here for my venom 2
trailer video and click here for that
new spider-man 3 Tom Horn clip thank you
so much for watching everyone stays safe
I'll see you guys tonight
you